foreign
work with Nico matajek and Mike Powell
um also at Kellogg
um so what we're interested in here is
um the internal organization of the firm
that makes a modular product so that is
a product that is made by basically
assembling a limited number of
separately produced modules
specifically we want to know who should
be talking to who in a firm that makes
modular products so what should your
optimal communication Network look like
why are we interested in this because
modular products are incredibly common
modular products are so ubiquitous now
that the 21st century has been referred
to as the modular age so here are just
three examples for you so this is the
iPhone and it's showing you the
different modules the different
components that together make up the
iPhone and here's the famous One the 787
the Boeing Dreamliner was famous for its
modular production so basically the
different components that you see were
sort of made separately and then all
brought to the Boeing factory in
Washington at the end of the process
where they were assembled together to
make the plane
[Music]
[Music]
that's producing these things and we
think of what we're doing as really a
first step because this kind of
production is going to lead not only to
changes in your organization but
potentially whether you want to
Outsource or not
um it's true and some of these are
actually stating the outside
okay so the third picture is what's
known as a design structure Matrix a DSM
this is for a laptop computer
um so basically what the horizontal axis
the different rows are the different
tasks or inputs involved in making this
laptop computer so you basically have
the different
tasks involved in the drive system
I can't read that so I guess you can't
the main board then the different tasks
in the LCD screen and then the different
casting packaging so in LC in the LCD
screen this could be
um the panel right the back of the
screen the bezel the kind of frame the
hinges and so on okay and so these four
groups of tasks here are the four
different modules okay to see the
modularity you have to understand the
crosses so along the
horizontal axis you have the same tasks
as you have along the vertical axis and
across in The Matrix indicates a need
for coordination between those two tasks
right so if you look here I want to know
whether sort of the extent to which the
tasks involved in the LCD screen should
be coordinated with each other I end up
in this box here and you see there are
many crosses right it's really important
that my panel fits well with the back
fits well with the bezel and so on
but if we go across to here this is the
extent to which the sort of sorry tasks
in the LCD screen need to be coordinated
with tasks and packaging and there are
fewer crosses yes these things need to
be coordinated to some extent but
there's a sort of a I guess we might
think of a less precise need for for
coordination right and so the modularity
you can see with the block structure
there's a strong need for coordination
Within These different between tasks
Within These different modules and and a
less of a need for for coordination
across
calculations
yes so
as in how did how did they do this
um what does it mean for one to need to
coordinate with the other and the other
one not to need to coordinate with
so it's like one has to be made first or
something or
so that's
one of my co-opers got to a talk where
somebody
so that people spend a long time trying
to put these things together and let so
they will do various things like ask you
know who do you which sort of components
do you need to sort of
um match with sort of some have to be
designed to match with others but not
basic person in our model however that's
something I guess we're going to happen
very very quickly and that's
partly in a
substance
[Music]
are you going to do that oh yes
um yes
and this is kind of what I showed you up
because you know maybe it's prompting
you to think how how we might think
about
we're gonna in order to answer a
question are we gonna need to think
about how to model modular production
yeah uh okay so these are just three
examples there are many many more many
electronic products and modular cars are
made modular houses are made modular
even non-physical products so software
programs are often modular where you
have sort of sub Pro sub programs that
do a particular function that you can
sort of switch in and out if
if you need to
right so we're interested in in the
impact of modular production on the
internal organizational funds right so
so this is coming back to a question we
think of this
as a sort of first step in understanding
this wide scale increase in in modular
production right and First Step because
you might think that you know if I
produce a modular product that's going
to have an impact on the way I organize
but then potentially have an impact on
boundaries of the firm maybe I start
Outsourcing this module right and then
over time that might have an impact on
structure of Industries nature of
competition and and so on and so we're
sort of taking what we think is the
immediate first step of how is that
going to impact the organization
of the phone
um
so in order to answer this we're going
to need to model modular production
um
right so we're going to need to think
about the inputs into production as well
as as the way that those different
inputs are coordinated with each other
once we've modeled modular production
we're then going to ask our question
about what should what does optimal
communication look like
um
if your production is modular
now more broadly we're sort of
interested in understanding how the
structure of a technology so your
production the nature of your production
function is going to impact
organizational structure so you might
think that the nature of production so
it's your is your product modular or not
is going to have an impact on how you
want to organize so the management
literature actually has a lot just
discusses this a lot
um
organizational economics not so much and
we think that's because the way so if we
model production has has been somewhat
too simplistic to do that so either we
sort of think of two decisions kind of
two inputs all we think of sort of many
decisions or many inputs but with equal
need for coordination between
and obviously if you want to think about
this you're going to have to think about
sort of different needs for coordination
across different inputs
um and now you see where we're going to
need some networks
um and yeah and so so more so sort of
more broadly we want to to sort of
improve our understanding of how
how sort of different features of
production impact impact
um organizational structure
okay
okay
so
okay
uh okay so I want to try and show you
the model in two slides in two pictures
brother
um
so
we're going to think of a single firm
producing a single product
each node that you see I guess look at
one of these screens each node that you
see here it's an agent who's in charge
of making some decisions so think of you
know this guy here is in charge of
producing the it's in charge of
Designing the LCD panel
right each agent is associated
um each agent each sorry decision is
associated with an idiosyncratic ideal
set okay so you should think of that as
the ideal way of Designing the the LCD
panel
the Sun the size of the nodes that you
see indicate the need for how important
it is to be to adapt your decision to
that ideal State and the links that you
see between these nodes indicate the
need for coordination between the
different decisions they were a thicker
a thicker line indicates a stronger
but you can also see the the module in
nature so
the decisions are are partitioned into
modules so I practiced into groups with
a stronger needs for coordination within
and a weekly for coordination across and
here I flash up again the CSM which is
what we're
replicate that
Okay so
this modular production function is a
primitive of the model we're taking that
as given that is the problem that the
production problem that that our our
designer faces okay
um and then what the designers are going
to choose is communication
so our organizational designer is going
to be choosing which agent should tell
which other agent about his
idiosyncratic ideal state so maybe this
guy should be telling this guy
maybe this guy's gonna tell this guy his
eye his State he's going to tell this
guy his State maybe this guy here is
[Music]
this so partly put this up because I
want to highlight that there are going
to be two networks floating around in
this talk the first is that is the
modular production Network which is
exogenously given It's A Primitive of
the model and then the second is what
we're going to be designing which is is
optional communicate
so one thing that I'm gonna come back to
is is right so there are many
possibilities for this communication
Network right this is one of them this
is the idea this is the sort of one of
the Hallmark features of the management
literature is the idea that perhaps if
you have a production function that's
modular you might end up with an
organization that sort of mirrors that
to some extent so we're going to have
lots of communication Within These
modules and less across and so I'm gonna
characterize optimal communication and
then come back to when this might be the
case
Okay so
are you telling us so I have this
optimal choice but now I depend on
YouTube
says
this sounds like if I even if I knew all
of them like that
are you telling us how we help us all
exist
good this is the slide no there are no
incentives yeah so the trade so that's
not the trade-off in this model the
trade-off in this model is coming from
Team Theory so this is the idea that
that communication is costly so it's
cognitively costly you know I'm an
engineer it's cognitively costly for me
to tell you this complex piece of
information it's cognitively costly for
you to understand no no but I still have
to understand
what can I use the computation for
because my ideal state is just
influenced by your ideal state right so
now
okay
um I'm going to jump to the model
straight after and I think that will um
hopefully clear up where there's
Independence
um
yes okay but the trade-off is going to
be basically Communications costly so on
the one hand I'm going to pull back I'm
going to want to sort of reduce
communication within the organization on
the other hand more communication is
going to help us to make better
decisions we're going to end up making a
better product and so that's the
trade-off so here we're following
in the footsteps of Panera's 1974 but
where he writes since information is
costly it's clearly optimal in general
to reduce internal transmission that is
it pays to have some loss in value for
the some loss in value for the choice of
terminal act in order to economize on on
internal communication channels and that
is the trade-off where we want to
capture in this model
um
he goes on to say the optimal choice of
internal communication structures the
vastly difficult question we definitely
found it difficult until we realize that
in the specific setting that I'm going
to show you in just a second we can
actually make quite a lot of progress on
on characterizing optimal communication
using sort of quite standard
economics
so I want to highlight one paper here
because I said that most sort of people
thinking about production functions
available the model two decisions or
many decisions but with equal need for
coordination between them
um
an exception is called mango de Martian
Pratt which model the different needs
for coordination between different
decisions sort of the main difference
here is that we're assuming a modular
production function and that's going to
allow us to make some progress and
characterize more optimal communication
okay so let me jump into the model so
things get clearer so there's a single
firm producing a product
there are n agents
yeah I do I do okay so each agent is in
charge of making a decision so I'm some
agent I
I'm in charge of making a decision I a
decision di about some part of the
laptop when other agents are in charge
of making other decisions
where D is just a large scaler
each decision is associated with a state
beta which again is just a real number I
this is think of this as the ideal way
to design my part of the laptop it might
depend on consumer tastes it might
depend on advances in technology and
prices and so on
and then some decisions are are linked
to each other
output is gonna be higher right we're
going to produce a better product the
more each decision is is adapted to its
state and the closer two decisions are
to each other
specifically we're going to model output
our Revenue function our output function
like this
but uh I think it's easier to see that
the first order condition there are two
important parameters here
um AI which is how important it is for
me to adapt
to my ideal state right and we model
this by the size of the node a bigger
node in case it's more important to
adapt to my state and the PID which is
how important it is for me to to get
close to Jake's decision
you can also kind of write you can also
write this as a standard quadratic loss
right uh losses are increasing the
further I am from my state the further I
am
okay
so that's production
um right
[Music]
so if you set our eyes DJs are between
minus E and plus b it's a DI again in
between
the pH is up to one or something oh yeah
so we're going to make the assumption
that pages are less than one to get you
I mean if if that are I is D and
the DJs are also all these and my drip
uh okay I'm missing I so the answer is
no we don't have to make any
restrictions on the Theta eyes other
than this right existence I would have
expected
the AIS
yes because otherwise you could input
something which is obesity of balance
and your output something which does
that's what the answer is no not in our
proof but maybe this is something we
could talk about after looking
but yeah
um
um
we do need PID less than one
so this key here is gonna
um it's a piece of notation this is
going to denote the The Matrix with
these entries which are the the
dependencies between the different
decisions
is very low she would want to take some
boundary action is that the point
because if AI is very large then the DI
you might want to choose might be bigger
than that if AI is 10 000 feet
I think the summation of pij together
with AI
that's my question
I do yeah okay let's uh I'll have to
look after at like whether we but yeah
um
that's not what we mean but maybe we've
dropped an AI from somewhere and we need
to add it back in
um but yeah
um
but you're saying it needs to contain AI
so yeah
okay
thanks
um okay
so that describes production
okay so that describes production but we
want to think about a modular production
function so we're going to model
we're going to restrict the network in a
sense each agent is going to belong to a
module
with NM members so these guys belong to
this module one module two module three
um one more piece of notation Mi is
going to give the module that the agent
I belongs to
the need for coordination between any
two any two any two decisions in
different modules is going to be given
by P
the need for coordination between any
two decisions in the same module is PM
so for this module it's P1 this one is
P2 and the other one is P3 okay so
that's the production problem that the
that the the designer faces
what about information so each state
these are the idiosyncratic States each
state is drawn independently from a
distribution of mean zero some variance
um each agent observes his own ideal
state
what is the what does communication look
like the principal can place directed
communication links between Pairs of
agents at some fixed costs so if the
principal places a communication link
from agent I to Agent J we donate this
we don't we denote this by CI J equal to
one and what that means is that I tells
Jay the realization
there's going to be a fixed cost gamma
per link if if I and J are in different
modules we assume the cost is zero if
they're in the same module that's not at
all important for the results and we can
get rid of that but it makes them easier
to state
and if there's no link for my today then
we denote it CID equal to one so this is
our other Matrix floating around which
is the communication Matrix with event
would be zero one entries so a row in
this Matrix row I is going to summarize
who knows State I a column J is going to
summarize
what states J knows
okay so the principle is going to design
the communication Network to maximize
expected output
subject to the cost of communication
and then the timing is is it's probably
what you think it is the principal is
going to design the communication
Network
agents are then going to learn their
states and tell them to other agents
according to the communication Network
agents then simultaneously make their
decisions
to um to maximize expected output
remember this is team Theory right so
each agent is going to be every agent is
going to be maximizing this expected
output
um hey I also realized and then the game
we're interested in what does the
optimal communication Network look like
foreign
so first of all I want to for a given
communication Network what are the
decisions that agents are making okay so
the the organizational designer designs
the communication Network agents learn
their states they tell them to other
agents according to the communication
Network and then agent simultaneously
make that decision right so each agent
is Optum is is maximizing the expected
output subject to the the information
that that on the state study has
this is the best response function that
comes out of that I'm going to put some
weight on my state and I'm going to put
some weight on the on the decisions I
expect my neighbors to
listen and then equilibrium decisions
are unique they're given by this
expression here so
each agent's decision is is a weighted
sum of the states so what is the Wake
that decision I puts on this on this on
state J well it's AJ which was how
important it was for Jay to to adapt to
his stake and Omega i j
um which is and we'll just put it in
words it's a valuable what's from node I
to J on the production Network that go
only through agents who know
the next station
okay so suppose Jay tells inj so j-12
ink his state
then Omega ID is basically all the what
swim though like today on on this
um
uh is the
I actually took this out I don't know
why it should look just like today it's
um it's the the pij is the the
the product of the weights
of the links that the world traverses
foreign
I care about coordinating with your
decision you're going to put some weight
on your state so I'm going to put some
weight on your state but you want to
coordinate with your neighbor's decision
right so you're going to put some weight
on their state and so I'm going to put
some weight on their site and so that's
why the walks matter right but we only
count the water everybody in the walk
knows the final State that's because if
anybody doesn't know the final state
like the expectation of that final that
the states have means zero so their
expectation of that final set is zero
and so hierarchively so zero and so
those end up canceling out
right and so the thing that you would
imagine should happen if I don't know
State J then the weight that I put on
this is
okay
why am I telling you this because
there's one object here which is going
to be end up being important and that's
the weight that this a decision eye puts
on his own state so a I oh my God I
foreign
this is going to end up being important
in a minute so let me give you a bit of
intuition for this so we think of AI as
capturing the degree of autonomous
adaptation this is basically how much I
adapt to my own state if nobody else
knows it
in which case you can think of Omega i i
as the coordination multiplier that's
how much extra weight I put on my state
when you know it right when you know my
State we care about coordinating so
you're gonna put a bit of weight on my
state which allows because I care about
coordinating with you that allows me to
put a bit more weight on my face
and so this Omega II is increasing in in
the people who know my State more people
know my State I'm going to adapt to it
more
it's also super modular
okay so if you know my State you're
going to adapt a little bit right if
Alex knows my state he's going to adapt
a little bit but you guys also care
about coordinating with each other so
you are holding back a bit but now you
both know you can both adapt a little
bit more and I can adapt a little bit
more and that's
very basic intuition for where the super
modularity was coming yeah and then the
super modularity is really going to be
driving
okay so the other important thing about
this is that it depends on who knows
State I it doesn't depend on what I or
anyone else know about any other state
okay so next step
okay
um
my organizational designer wants to
choose the best communication Network so
next thing I want to do is for a given
communication Network work out what
expected output expected Revenue looks
like so I'm going to plug both
equilibrium decisions for a given
communication Network to to find out
what expected Revenue looks like for
that communication Network
all I've done here is basically a
rewriting
of the revenue function
um it turns out this is zero so you can
see it's zero for two reasons either you
can plug in the decisions
or you can realize that this di this is
my
my decision my equilibrium decision
multiplied by my prediction error on
Jay's decision those two should be
intuitively should be also good okay
which means expected revenue is given by
this very simple sum of the aidi Theta I
um
and Di is just a covariance between the
decision and estate
so expected revenue is just given by the
sum of the weighted covariances between
the decision and its state so basically
expected Revenue just depends on how
well each decision is adapted to its
state
right the intuition is that that
adaptation also captures
coordination because I can adapt more to
my statement
when other people know it because then I
can coordinate that yes
yes
a coupling between states
no coupling between states like Theta i
j don't you ever need to account for
uh like my team can do something but if
my team does this another team cannot do
something else because those two are not
compatible
so we're thinking of that
as a sort of I guess right this is the
loss from us not coordinating right
so so my input needs to be coordinated
somewhat with your input and how we're
modeling that is is that you know the
sort of some increasing loss the worse
we are coordinated so there's some cost
what's up
you're awesome uh
like so what it
not quite but uh
um okay and then the covariance between
the decision and estate it can be
written like this where the sigma I is
the the variance to stay high
and so you see the AI oh my God
okay so this is really
um going to be really useful because
expected revenue is just the sum of
these things for each eye okay and we
saw before a key property of this Omega
II is it depends only on what people
know about State I am not what anybody
knows about any other state and so this
problem becomes separable
so instead of tackling the designer's
problem head on we can separate it into
simpler sub problems and ask who should
know about State one separately from who
should my state two who should know step
three who should know State four and so
on and so that's going to make it that's
going to really help us be able to say
something about optimal communication
Networks
okay second thing that's useful here is
the super modularity implies that if
it's optimal for if it's optimal for me
to tell you my state then it's optimal
for me to tell everybody in your module
my state
so really the principles problem breaks
down to for each agent which module
should he be informing about
if you say so now we've really broken
down the principle of the problem
we can start to say something about what
communication looks like and I think of
about 12 minutes left
okay
so
now I've broken it down to this the next
thing I want to do is write this
this thing here you can think of this as
the sort of the expected revenue
generated by agent I I want to write
this down in terms of Primitives of the
model
the next thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to rewrite this this agent
eyes expected Revenue in terms of the
model's Primitives
to make it easier to write down I'm
going to take agent One supposing agent
one is in module one
I'm going to write down agent one's
expected Revenue if agent one informs
everyone in his module as well as
everyone in modules two to L well I'm
just labeling those modules
yeah so if agent one informs modules one
to l
this is what age of one's expected
Revenue looks like
okay so you can see
um
XM popping out of it
what is this exam
we call it the cohesion of module M this
is basically a measure of the importance
of sort of coordinating within module m
versus outside
so this is going to be higher the more
decisions there are in my model that I
need to coordinate with and the higher
the importance of
hire these interdependencies
and it's going to be lower the more
important it is to coordinate outside
um okay so let me tell you a couple of
things about this so first of all a
there's this A1 this this Sigma 1
squared so these measure the value of
autonomous adaptation that's how much
revenue I generate if nobody nobody else
knows my state this is the sort of extra
Revenue I generate as I tell my own
module and this is the extra Revenue I
generate from telling you okay
so I'm not going to show you any proofs
here
and this is partly because the proofs
are in some sense basic algebra and
Matrix algebra this because this is the
part that took us a really long time
staring at it and manipulating things
until we finally got out something that
um was incredibly neat compared to what
we started with
um
and then this rewriting sort of
essentially sort of leads us into the
characterization of so let me show you
how you can see it right so you can see
that the
revenue generated by agent one is
increasing the more cohesive is is a
module that he tells
and the reason for that is
when I tell a module that is more
cohesive but it's the more cohesive
module has a higher importance of
coordination within the module versus
outside and therefore that model is
going to adapt more to my state when I
tell that module myself
which that means I can adapt
and so that's why more cohesive modules
are important the other thing that you
can kind of see for out of this is that
this is com this expression is convex in
the sum of nnzms
right so what this means
is that if it's optimal for me to tell
some module
then it's going to be optimal for me to
tell along a piece of my
life
which leads us straight to our
characterization
which says that for any agent to who is
that agent going to tell the state well
he's going to tell his module this state
right that that costs zero so of course
he's going to
um then he's that agent is going to have
a threshold and that
I and that agent is going to tell every
module whose cohesion is above this
question
so the the intuition that I gave you in
the previous slide
let me show you a picture so let's take
this guy in blue let's line up the
modules from least to most cohesive so
now I've dropped the links I'm
illustrating a more cohesive module with
a darker purple
so let's suppose this guys
threshold it's here
right he's going to tell everyone in the
state then he's going to tell the two
most cohesive modules if his threshold's
a bit lower he's going to tell the three
most cohesive module the destruction
what determines this threshold well the
lower communication costs the more
modules I'm going to tell but if it's
just not that important for me to adapt
to my state then I'm going to tell fewer
modules because it's just not that
important for you to know or if my state
doesn't vary much and the more
the bigger and the more important is
coordination within any module the more
modules I'm going to take that's an
adopt supermarket
okay so next slide what I want to do is
is put that characterization together
right so that characterization is is
telling you what a single agent will do
so it would put that characterization
together for all the N agents what does
the the what does this imply for for the
structure of the communication Network
well it results in a receiver hierarchy
so for any free agents in different
modules
if Agent J
hears from more
let me say that a different way
um basically an agent in the most
cohesive module
is going to hit everything from an agent
in a less cohesive module and possibly
more
so let me show you
for anybody who's talking is talking to
the most anybody who's telling their set
is telling their step to the most
cohesive anybody who's telling it so two
modules is telling it to the two most at
least anyone who's selling to three
modules is selling it to the three
months ago
all right so this is a nested hierarchy
property that we saw in Evans talk
yesterday right
um where if I'm hearing more than you
I'm hearing everything you're hearing
and and then possibly more so um I'm
getting a little bit lost and I think
you may have answered the question but
I'm not sure so you were starting out
with a design problem right the
principle is designing a communication
structure and then we solve this
backwards
um one thing that I'm missing is do the
agents have an incentive to obey the
principles communication structure and
um
yes because you've just shown us that or
not
that along the way or not I haven't
shown you so they don't have a choice
yet but okay so then the question is
would they want to undermine the
structure that the principal set up for
them
and the answer
haven't looked up for a long time but I
think it knows or there at least exists
in equilibrium that's what I'm wondering
it sounds like that's it's your software
but not
explicitly but it sounds like it might
be true at some point one of my co-opers
wrote A version where you can find an
equilibrium well age they want to treat
them I guess yes okay
uh it would be useful to write that out
because you know the principle sets up a
communication structure but in any of
these firms people go out to lunch
whatever they do you know so do they
want to obey the structure that the
principal sets up it should be incentive
compatible in some way but and it looks
to me like the problem reduces to the
extent that it that will be true but I
even know if this is the effects of what
you've done okay this is actually a
second question that I don't think that
we looked at which I think what we were
looking at is do I want to pass my my
message my stay alone my trees stay
along but actually you're saying do I
want to pass it to that person or to a
different one yeah okay right right
but we haven't thought about that so
that's a nice second question that we
hadn't thought about um well there's
both two questions yeah yes and we have
thought about the first one a while ago
um and yeah the second one I guess would
be yes but yeah
um
no that shouldn't be true because the
size of the dot affects only whether I
want to send information I'm not about
who I want to send it to
so it affects the the sender hierarchy
not the receiver hierarchy
okay
um
so let me tell you a couple more things
about this since the last minutes that I
have left so let me tell you what this
precludes
um maybe I don't need to say it here but
this precludes a two sport what's called
a two switch so if you have four agents
in different modules an agent I talks to
Agent K Agent J talks to L but Jay
doesn't talk to K and I doesn't talk to
L
um
nested hierarchical setup you can't have
that right
which sort of then leads us to
um preclude a bunch of structures that
we think are sort of natural in in the
organization space so here are my dots
and that's even here but they're my dots
are modules so it rules out something
like teams of teams where you have teams
of multiple modules where within those
teams those modules are all talking to
each other so you can't have a sort of a
teams of teams structure right you can't
have any kind of version of a tree or
really any hierarchies where I'm sort of
talking to a level above but but not to
all the levels of that foreign
so I should say here we're not saying
these structures should never occur in
organizations we're saying they should
never occur as communication structures
and they're not optimal sorry in as
communication structures and
organizations that that are producing
modular products
they're not certain
um okay let me tell you something last
of all
that is is permitted so if
my my threshold Landers take the same
ranking as as module cohesion so
basically if the most cohesive modules
those are the people who hear the most
if they also speak the most
then this this nested hierarchy
structure collapses to a corporate
where you have the core made of you have
sort of a big team made of the most
cohesive modules
and those modules all talk to each other
and then you have a periphery made of a
less cohesive modules where there's no
talking among these but they may be
feeding sort of information in and out
to the Core
okay
and then
um
I have one minute
do you have time so like yeah okay let
me wrap up
um okay well actually let me because I
promise to tell you this so let me say
one thing on this right does this occur
can this be an optimal communication
structure well I told you optimal
communication structure for hierarchies
this is a flat structure however you
know
I
hierarchy just a sort of corner solution
and the answer is this does occur but
under some very fine conditions right
you can't have too many modules they
can't be too big the importance of
coordination can't be too much because
super modularity is just pushing me all
the way
um
and same thing for sort of teams of
teams super modularity is going to be
pushing you back to a sort of one big
team as as your central team and then
okay so over the last half a century the
economy shifted more and more towards
modular production this paper is the
first step in thinking about the
implications of that
um there are other really quite
interesting questions out there so one
of the things which I thought might have
been your question was about interfaces
this is the idea of how these firms
design the sort of the the parts that
fit together between the different
modules right really interesting
questions here so they talk about IBM
which shifted from from sort of building
its computer I guess kind of this
intricate system of of its different
parts to a modular computer at that
point IBM changed its organizational
structure but it then started to
Outsource over time more and more of its
modules and so that changed the
boundaries of the firm it then changed
competition within the commute computer
industry and sort of kind of many many
other interesting things happened and I
think the the a really interesting
question here that we think is difficult
to tackle within economics right now is
the reason for the rise of modular
production in the first place and the
reason we think it's kind of difficult
to tackle in economics is because we
tend to take production functions as
given by nature and so you know the the
sort of the trade-offs the costs and
benefits of designing your your
production function is is as far as we
know it's not something that's
thanks very much
there's one over there
so
it's just a matter of interpretation
are nodes within the same scope of your
model but should we think of them as
having more correlated information
is
um
okay so this is a question about is this
a question about the sort of
independence of states or the cost of
communication Independence and States
independence and States yeah
yes I mean
it's a shock talk so I didn't talk about
sort of our assumptions and where
they're necessary but independence of
States it's buying us a lot of
tractability because it allows us to
separate into sub modules I think
there's good reason there's good
examples of States being independent
um right so often products are very
complex and the sort of the
technological advances in one part of a
product are very different from the
technological advances in another right
consumers might care about the body of
the car but they may not care about some
interior parts of the car so these are
sort of my examples of the state and so
they're you know I think there are good
examples where these things are
independent I think there's also good
examples where they're not and maybe
that might tend to be the case less
within modules
um
and yeah
I think that would be interesting to
think about if we restricted it to
within modules would we be able to
yeah I think that's a nice question
could we make some extra progress there
because if we restricted it within
modules I don't know but maybe yeah no
it seems hard but but I was just curious
kind of how to think about different
things like if we if we need to build
things that are very compatible but we
still
don't know very much about this sort of
each other without prior to talking it's
okay
foreign
cost of communication I think so this is
the idea we might already if we're
working on some inputs in the same
module we might share similar expertise
and so this is sort of one justification
for having the cost of communication
being zero within a margin
so yeah I guess yeah
although we don't need
foreign
[Music]